so what do you think the right gets
wrong oh okay that's a good question
um so if you were going to vote who
would you be leaning towards did having
a baby change any of your political
views or values a bunch of people asked
this question they wanted your opinion
on what the most valuable qualities to
look for in a man are and also values
men should look for in women there are
so many things men are kind of told like
build yourself up a lot which is good
you should build yourself up but it's
like women are told do what makes you
happy or like follow your heart and
stuff like that don't waste your time
like there are these posts where people
will blow up at each other over like a
trivial thing and everyone in the
comments is like it's not actually about
this thing you guys have deeper issues
and this just happened to be the straw
that broke the camel's back I also think
one mistake people can make when they're
dating is um being okay this is a
mistake that I've made so that's why I'm
bringing it up but
is orange Chen welcome to my
podcast hey thanks for having me I'm
excited to be here it's been a while
since we spoke so this is this is fun it
has I can't remember the last time you
might have still been in Canada I think
so I think so so are you in Nashville
now yes we're in Nashville we've been
here since last February so over a year
now and we're just we're loving it like
not 2023 February
2022 and you love it improvement over
were you in Quebec yes we were in Quebec
we were outside of Montreal so not only
we were in Canada but we were in
authoritarian French Canada that
literally had some of the strictest coid
measures in the entire world so we were
we were really glad to be out of there I
feel like so Toronto was really bad and
I think the only place that was worse
than Toronto was Quebec yeah yeah yeah I
I feel like that's a true statement in
many ways not just Co
measures so yeah know Toronto it's crazy
because I I used to to remember going to
visit when I was a kid and I thought it
was kind of cool almost like New York
yeah in a bad way that's true now and
that like New York the crate the crime
is crazy the cost of living is crazy I
just don't understand how people are
doing it in
Toronto yeah it's pretty bad I hadn't
been there in a couple years after I
moved to the us and we went down this
one street called Sherburn downtown and
it was so much worse than it was during
Co so it hadn't turned around at all it
was really scary and I'm pretty used to
like living I always live downtown and
they're always homeless people I was
like that's totally fine this was like
people on drugs very concerning and so
that's still going on it's
sad no definitely and I feel like Canada
has been so lucky for the longest time
the the idea that oh all big cities are
just kind of crime ridden homeless
people drug addicts on the street that
didn't used to be the case in Canada I
mean places like Montreal Toronto and
Vancouver for the longest time they were
almost European level of crime despite
being Urban North American areas but
that's really changed especially over
the last 10 years my parents lived in
Ottawa for a spell and Ottawa if you're
American if you've never been there it's
basically the quaintest cutest City or
at least it used to be but now similar
problems there are homeless people who
are aggressive on drugs on the street uh
you know there are stabbings that are
happening it's like what happened to you
know this this perfect almost idilic
country where we had all these resources
everyone was friendly got along we
didn't have any problems it seems like
literally now every problem is getting
worse in Canada I don't know if people
in Montreal were ever friendly do you
have that do you speak French yeah I
mean I'm not amazing my husband he's
perfectly fluent I can get by but I
wouldn't like for example the things
were probably going to be talking about
in this interview I don't think I'd be
able to do that in French okay that's
still pretty impressive though yeah I
mean it's they kind of they kind of make
it mandatory when I moved to Quebec for
the first time I was born there but I
didn't go to like I didn't grow up in
Quebec I grew up in Asia so I was in I
think fifth grade the first time I went
to school in Quebec and I just literally
was in immersion so I just had half of
my schooling in French so it was kind of
like okay you're going to learn this or
you're not going to understand anything
and make no friends so didn't really
have a choice wow okay okay before we
get into things can you give a brief
background for anybody who's not
familiar with you of who you are and
what it is you do sure so I'm a Blaze TV
host as well as a tpusa contributor and
I guess YouTuber all of my content is up
on YouTube and I talk about a lot of
different things kind of like you I I
talk about current events and social
issues but uh I do that on my main
Channel Lauren Chen but I also talk a
lot about pop culture and entertainment
news on my media holic channel so I kind
of like to do both and I feel like
nowadays especially those Realms
politics social issues and entertainment
they're increasingly overlapping um just
because everything is political nowadays
so there's even times where I want to
talk about a story but I'm like hang on
which which category to this fall under
because it's not always so clear that is
so true I feel like American politics
are even worse like I remember watching
American politics when I was young and
being like oh this is just entertainment
compared to Canadian politics and now
everything's kind of Blended together
maybe because of social media yeah
you're definitely right I mean we have
like Katie Perry when she was wearing
that like Hillary Clinton like go vote
outfit it's almost like American Idol
American politics at this point so it's
there's a lot of overlap there and it's
such a stark contrast to Canadian
politics which is still almost more like
British politics and that it's very dry
it's not you know money chiz flashiness
where you have you know uh people on
campaigns who basically have like
millions of dollars of like hair makeup
and wardrobe like no Canadian politics
is not like that at all no Cho might be
a little bit like that
now a bit alth whenever he's spending on
hair and makeup he might need to spend
more cuz I still don't know what was
happening with those eyebrows that that
one time that was weird hey everyone if
you are unfortunate enough to be
suffering from a mood disorder or some
sort of virus or cold or want to
increase your lifespan detoxify feel
perked up you should try saing if you
watch huberman or Ronda Patrick or Joe
Rogan or any health person you've heard
of saing and I can't really describe how
much it helps you feel better we're
getting exposed to so many chemicals and
toxins in the modern world we need help
detoxing just to survive Bond charge is
my go-to sauna blanket it works by
helping you detox and sweat it raises
your heart rate like exercise so it
burns calories it's super easy to set up
and clean and you can even travel with
it seems to improve my mood by about 30%
after I use it which is significant
that's usually how I judge the efficacy
of things by
mood free shipping easy returns and
exchanges 30-day trial 12 months
warranty it has everything it gives the
same benefits as a built-in sauna using
far infrared panels but it's super
affordable it can fit anywhere go to
bond charge.com MP and use code MP to
save
15% that's b o n c h r g.com slmp and
use code MP to say 15% linked in the
comments okay so you have a baby right
how recent was that oh well I guess now
she's technically a toddler not a baby
anymore which is like she's growing up
but she's 17 months so she's born April
of 2022 wow okay how how have you
managed to that Congratulations by the
way thank you yeah I have a my
daughter's six now which is insane so
she just went to grade one it's crazy
she's gorgeous by the way I've seen her
photos on Instagram she looks so much
like you a thank you well I should hope
so had to birth her so like I should
hope so um how did you manage continuing
social media continuing all the
different projects you're involved in
and also taking care of a baby is that
tricky oh it it is tricky like it's
definitely something that I don't think
would work for everybody and my husband
and I we were really really conscious
like when we I guess got married and
we're planning to have kids that we both
wanted to be able to be home as much as
possible so um my husband and I we've
worked together I guess on this social
media video stuff for over 5 years for
sure at this point Point um so we're in
a position where if one of us is working
the other can be watching Riley and we
also now have at least my parents close
by to help out so we are very blessed in
the setup that we have and I know like
in the conservative Movement we all want
obviously moms and dads too but
especially moms as involved with their
kids as possible and I I've seen some
shaming for moms that do still have to
work um and I you you know I I feel like
I'm in a position where like I get to
stay home with my kid and I I get to
work but I know not everyone is that
fortunate and I do wish that people
especially in the conservative sphere
would understand that yeah yeah it's not
a good thing if a Mom is putting her
career before her children or a father
like children should come first but we
also live in a real world where it's for
most people not sustainable to only have
one income and you know acting like
you're blind to that is not uh it's it
it's it's not very endearing for the
majority of people
yeah I had a weird experience um when I
had Scarlet I was in a very liberal I
was like downtown Toronto very liberal
neighborhood so any of the neighbors
that came by were like 35 with kids and
I was 25 and it was always oh what do
you do and I had like just had a baby so
I was like well what I do now is like
recover from giving birth but like what
do you do and I was like well I'm
staying at home this was just for the
you know when she was really little for
the first like N9 months or so I was
like I'm staying at home with a baby
that's what I'm doing and it was kind of
like oh like oh that's what you're
spending your time doing and then so
that was like the liberal side and then
you get to the conservative side and I'm
working now and the conservative side is
kind of the
same except complete opposite where it's
oh oh you're working and be nice to have
like a little bit of an in between
sometimes yeah no it is it is hard like
there are very very competing
expectations of what you're supposed to
do as a mom um which ultimately when you
have your baby basically as a mom like I
I I think it's very it's pretty rare for
a mom to be like oh I don't want to be
able to provide for my kid or spend time
with them so it's not it's not helpful
really for most moms and I'm in some
group mom chats and we talk a lot about
how we're shamed one way or the other uh
for having to work or not working enough
whatever it may be yeah yeah um what do
you think so I've got a bunch of fun
questions for you here so what do you
think the right gets
wrong um well I mean we just kind of
touched on that uh like shaming and it's
not just you know shaming moms who might
have to work to provide for like help
provide for their families it's also I
mean I've seen right wiers like shaming
um you know 20 some year olds who are
still living at home because rents are
so expensive and they're trying to
juggle going to college while also
saving up like I don't think that's you
know and it's crazy because I saw this
one account that was I tweeted out
something about how I don't think it's a
bad thing to stay at home while you're
in school and save money um I think it's
actually pretty common in most cultures
outside of North America especially this
one account was just slam basting um
basically lazy jenzy Millennials who do
nothing they just want to I guess Smo
off their parents and I click their
profile and you know was scrolling
through they were complaining about
inflation eating up their savings and
making it unaffordable and unsustainable
and it's like so you understand the
problem do you not have any sympathy for
young people who are just coming into
the job market so I think that's not
helpful um yeah I think just in in
general
obviously you want people to have
personal responsibility and to take
control of their Destinies but at the
same time that doesn't change the fact
that if you're if you're slamming Joe
Biden for his terrible policies
obviously it's because those policies
are making it harder on people I don't
think it's being a bleeding hearted lib
to acknowledge that it's it's hard now
and it's not the worst thing if if if if
a you know student especially is living
with their parents instead of Roommates
to save money or if if if a mom has to
take up some shifts because it's just
too hard on only her husband's
salary yeah that seems reasonable I can
get behind that um how did you meet your
husband and find somebody who was kind
of willing to or interested not willing
but like interested in in helping the
social media uh thing you do I do the
same thing with my husband by the way
which is like when I was looking well I
wasn't even really looking for somebody
I was just
hoping more than looking but um I I
thought it was going to be very tricky
because I figured everything I'm doing
online plus wanting to have kids I'd
need somebody who could help me and who
wanted to build the same things that I
wanted to build and so I was I was
worried that I wasn't going to be able
to find anybody but you seem to have a
similar setup with your husband where
you're both working towards the same
goals how' you manage that well I mean
like you mentioned it is kind of like
when you have a job like this and you
want family it's almost like you you're
not just looking for a partner in one
area they need to be a partner in all
areas like not just like in the
relationship but also with like
Parenthood and also the business it's
kind of hard to separate them when you
do some like a job like ours so uh I
actually met my husband when I was 21 so
I either I think I was like just just
starting my YouTube channel and it was
still just something I did as a hobby on
the side I never would have imagined it
would be a career um and so we kind of
we started dating and then eventually it
became YouTube became like a part-time
job and then a full-time job and um you
know my husband he was he was still a
student because I graduated early and um
he graduated a little bit later so he
was still a student at the time and um
he was looking for a different job and
we were just getting or I was just
getting a a contract my first like of
official contract with crtv which is now
Blaze TV and um I was looking for an
editor so I was like well hey why don't
you want to edit my videos and kind of
you know do that it might be weird and
people cautioned us against it uh you
know because I understand how that could
get messy but um yeah I mean it worked
out and we've kind of been together and
working together ever since and over
that time like our our business has
changed we don't just do YouTube videos
now obviously his role has change like
now we do we deal with like advertisers
and different contracts like stuff with
tpusa and blae and he's kind of there to
help manage it all and it's been kind of
crazy to see how it's it's evolved as a
business and I'm I'm very fortunate that
he's been there throughout it all
because I mean you I'm sure you
understand it can be lonely doing what
we do because it's not like you're going
to the office every day right so there's
not a lot of people who you can talk to
that might understand exactly what
you're going through so having you like
a spouse where you're able to kind of
vent about whatever is happening online
it's it's really nice yeah I feel that
um when I first started doing on so I
think you started before me for sure um
but I got more involved in 2018 and 2017
I was kind of working in the background
on Dad's brand and that was like all
remote work and I was going to like
coffee shops just to be around people so
that I wasn't like at home on my
computer just
24/7 being lonely so yeah I feel that
it's fun though I would wouldn't change
it but I like and I get people
cautioning like it's tough to be able to
work with someone and be in a
relationship with them cuz then you're
with them all the time It's Tricky you
have to be with the right person
otherwise you just go crazy exactly and
I don't I don't know if it's like this
for you guys um but it's like I I've
gotten pet peeves about my husband that
I'm sure most PES don't have like he
doesn't CC me as much as I want to be
cced oh yeah yeah which is like a very
specific criticism to have of someone
you're in a relationship with but it's
like yeah like you do get to know your
spouse in a whole different dimension
because they're not just like your
romantic or like domestic partner
they're your business partner too that's
really funny yeah no I I completely
agree I just had that conversation with
with Jordan which was just he's because
he gets annoyed at me for not C seeing
him too like you can't get annoyed at me
if you're not C seeing me yeah I feel
that his like his excuse is like well
you can just ask me it's like or I could
just be included from the beginning and
know in real time kind of like what the
status is so I don't even need to ask
you so I could just read it yeah yeah
yeah have you have you taken a
personality test before uh yes I have
taken the Myers Briggs one I think it's
called or Myers Briggs um I I've heard
that it's kind of been it's falling out
of favor as the standard one but that's
I think the only one that I've taken you
should try dad has a understand.com and
it gives you your Big Five personality
just be interested to see yours cuz I I
think as a like especially as a woman in
the more conservative space I think you
have to be fairly disagreeable compared
to the average female and so if you're
you're also telling your husband like CC
me and then I'd be more involved just be
interested to see what your
agreeableness is do you think you're
somebody who's who's more
disagreeable I I feel like I am I am
pretty agreeable whether I'm more
disagreeable than the average woman I
think I'm more I'm more agreeable than
the average man for sure um I think my
mom is definitely a more disagreeable
woman so I'm more agreeable than her but
that is like like you mentioned being a
woman and conservative especially in the
conservative sphere I have wondered
whether my personality tends toward more
of a masculine archetype in some ways
just because of that and because like I
I I do feel like my my Myers Brigg's
personality type is intj so I do feel
like I'm less emotional than a lot of
women that's for
sure okay maybe it could be that my
mom's also way more disagreeable than me
she was so disagreeable growing up it
was unbelievable my dad was like the
agreeable one so maybe taking after her
yeah weird huh that's strange yeah
interesting okay did having a baby
change any of your political views or
values or do you think take anything
more seriously or less seriously than
you did before having a baby um I don't
know if
you encountered this but I mean
obviously anytime you hear about about
something bad happening to children it's
awful and terrible but especially since
I got pregnant and had Riley now like I
hear a story about something bad
happening to especially like a young
baby or a toddler and I I will keep me
up at night for days and days and uh I
like I don't think it was it wasn't that
I wasn't that empathetic toward children
um before I actually had one and now I'm
I've gotten much more like if you do
anything to a kid I don't care like you
need to be strung up I'm sorry and I'm
I'm not really for the death penalty
just because I'm I'm very critical of
state power and I feel like there's a a
little bit of a conflict of interest
there when it's kind of like the state
is trying you and sentencing you I just
I feel like it can be a recipe for
disaster but at the same time if you're
a pedophile or a an abuser of children
like why are we keeping you alive though
like yeah like we can discuss but it's
like ultimately like if we know you did
it like why are you being kept alive is
kind of where I'm at and you know
there's there was all that conversation
surrounding the sound of freedom I
wasn't I wasn't able to watch that just
because I I knew it would be too
upsetting okay so I was I was just
having this conversation literally two
days ago with Jordan um about you know
what brain changes you experience after
you have a kid that exact same thing
happened to me I've always been like
obviously that's always been a concern
when I'm sure it's been a concern for
you too but there is some sort of Brain
Change where you're more impacted
emotionally or if you see somebody
else's kid like I remember before having
kids if it was somebody else's kid and
it was kind of like they being
bratty it it was more removed than now
there's definitely more compassion
involved that I think was just brain
changes from having a baby it's been
wild I feel exactly the same way where
it hits on an emotional level it didn't
hit on before no it's that's exactly it
and I you know with with kids
misbehaving now I like you said I used
to kind of just be like over removed
from it or even kind of annoyed from it
but now I I am much more quick to put
myself in in that kid shoes like you're
probably tired it's been a hard day like
no one else wants to be on this airplane
I'm upset of course like it would be
hard for a kid to do that so I yeah
there definitely been mom brain changes
that have happened and those have I
think also affected my
politics yeah okay I've had the same
thing I feel like my reaction to kids
screaming on a plane might be a little
bit different it's more like that parent
should be shot that's more that's more
of my reaction is like what are they
doing to that child to making it like to
make it scream although sometimes there
are earaches like things happen on
planes sometimes the kids sick so it's a
little bit different so I don't know why
that's that's more my reaction but more
anger towards the parents than I think I
had before baby oh yeah yeah no poor
little
baby okay so you're not able to vote in
America then because you're Canadian
right yeah so I think the students I'd
be able to vote here if I did like go
through citizenship would be um like
with every paperwork and stuff like at
least five six years or something like
that yeah and are you planning I mean
you don't have to tell me but are you
planning on going through with it I
don't know like there are legal
ramifications to that as well as um
because right now I do have two
nationalities uh I am Canadian and I
also H I'm a Hong Kong National so I'm
not quite sure what the
I guess legal process would be uh with
in regard to that cuz I know you you can
be dual Canadian and us for sure I don't
know how that works with Hong Kong or
even what the status of Hong Kong will
be by the time I'm eligible so that's
kind of another thing to consider yeah I
thought about it for a while because
Jordan was like you're going to be an
American I was like you married an
immigrant sorry I know Canada doesn't
doesn't count as like immigrant in your
mind but like I'm not American I'm
Canadian um yeah and I don't think I
don't think I'm going to go through with
it I'm here on a work visa right now and
there's just it's a lot America holds a
lot of power when they when they when
you have an American passport especially
if you end up moving out of America then
it's kind of a mess yeah ex especially
for the tax reasons alone I mean Uncle
Sam has like worldwide tax so that I
mean I I love America but also that's
definitely something to consider yeah
yeah yeah for sure so if you were going
to vote though who would you be leaning
towards in the next election I mean I
don't think people would be surprised to
hear that obviously I would support the
Republican uh
candidate now I I know a lot of people
are have real big feelings about what's
going on in the primaries Trump versus
DeSantis but I'm someone who's of the
belief like I have criticisms and I mean
Pros for both Trump and DeSantis but I
mean ultimately either one of them is
better than Joe Biden or I think anyone
who the Democrats would offer up right
now so it's it's kind of just like yeah
I would I would side with the
Republicans and I'm actually VC uh he
says a lot of stuff that I agree with
but I think like a lot of people I'm
just kind of you know there's the
question of is is he just going with the
flow a little bit too much is can we
trust him to live his values once he's
elected in office that's hard because he
is like he's so young he's new to the
scene in terms of politics so it's it's
almost like he's a bit of an unknown in
that regard yeah that's fair how how do
you feel about
Kennedy so I I have a lot of especially
family members who are big Kennedy fans
and I do like a lot of what he does I
love the push back on things like all of
the vaccine mandates and I think he is
actually someone who is interested in
criticizing and pushing back against big
Pharma where it's it's the the American
Medical system is such a mess and I know
the Canadian one is too but I feel like
often times if you criticize one people
think you're in favor of the other but I
I have criticisms of both I think
neither one is good and I I think
especially the the strangle hold that
big Pharma has on American um medicine I
think it's it's it's detrimental to
People's Health we're just being pumped
full of pills instead of actually making
lifestyle changes that could make us
healthier so I like that he's willing to
speak out against that and I think there
are too many politicians who are
Republicans and Democrats who are
frankly just bought and paid for when it
comes to Big Pharma lobbyists uh but
that said he is still a leftist um he's
not you know a woke
Elizabeth Warren type of leftist but I
wouldn't support him in an election for
sure maybe as a maybe a specific cabinet
appointment if there was a task force to
go against the vaccine manufacturers yes
let's put RFK on there but just in
general no he's he's too much of a
leftist for me I feel like I got dragged
into like liking Republicans when I
don't think I grew up that way at all I
grew up how did you grow up did you grow
up conservative like is your family
conservative or is that something that
you kind of chose at some point so I
grew up with my family being pretty
apolitical especially growing up in Asia
the political scene is just so different
there anyway um but definitely I would
say mostly a political I really don't
remember any discussions of politics in
in the house growing up but socially my
parents were I would say for sure more
conservative and not even I guess
explicitly but it's just you know I look
at some of the things that are being
pushed by more Progressive people and
it's like okay that never would have
flown when I was a kid you know the the
idea of like even having like a boy
sleepover at my house or something like
that that would not have flown just it
was I was I I guess I I had very firm
boundaries growing up which I think is a
good thing to have when you're a kid uh
and like very loving and caring parents
but I knew that obviously there are
consequences for actions there were
expectations that I had upon me and I I
was expected to live up to them so I I
started getting interested in I guess
more philosophy before politics and I
think you know I was reading a lot of
like through my brother I have an older
brother who kind of introduced me to a
lot of this stuff uh people like lock
and so I think that kind of influenced
me politically and then when I first
started getting into actual politics it
was kind of in like the bush era and I
knew George Bush was like before I was
even familiar with politics there would
just be like jokes about Republicans and
I kind of was like yeah like sure this
sounds good because I'm I'm a basically
a kid and I don't really know what's
going on but then like when I learned
more I didn't necessarily side with the
Republicans especially at that point
because it was during I mean 9/11 the
Iraq War and I'm I'm I you know I'm not
a neocon I'm not an interventionist in
any way shape or form but I I did know
that like people who were I guess
advocating for a lot of the more
left-wing or socialist policies that
they didn't represent me at all
so okay I don't have a walkway story I
wish I did though it would be a lot more
catchy if I were like I was a raging Li
but now look at me no no it's
interesting it's interesting I was I
think I don't know if I was like
apolitical probably I don't think I
cared about I still don't really care
about politics to be honest um but I was
definitely brought up in more of a
liberal household like dad's such a like
he's a fairly conservative like Figure
Head now and my family was not
particularly conservative like we had my
parents are so open like they were we
could negotiate I got I did way more
than I should have been able to do as a
teenager like you were talking about
having people sleepover maybe that's cuz
I had a younger brother but we had
sleepovers all the time not that they
were like weird sexual orgies or
something but like we had sleepovers
there weren't very many boundaries if
you could argue your case right and I
don't even know if the cases were argued
very well but like there weren't very
many boundaries it was kind of like
figure it out figure it out yourself
type of thing
which was probably I don't know if that
was helpful or not I don't know what
would have happened if there were firm
boundaries that I fought against there
were some and I fought against them so I
don't know if it would have helped if
they there were more firm boundaries but
it was pretty like my upbringing was
pretty liberal I would say liberal but
Dad didn't want to be told like what to
do by anybody so when it started getting
to the point where the government was
saying oh you have to do this you have
to do that then every body switch
directions pretty
quickly yeah and it's interesting how
like there are a lot of I think more
libertarian people out there who used to
identify more with the left but now
identify more with the right um even
though they're not necessarily more
conservative but just because they are
more libertarian or libertine the the I
guess flavor of leftist nowadays they're
very very authoritarian they definitely
want to tell you what to do yeah it's
wild it's wild um okay what what are
your thoughts oh actually first before
we get into that do you know what you're
going to do with I know this is a far
off in the future but do you plan on
homeschooling do you know what you're
going to do given the situation with
elementary schools is such a mess at
least you're in Tennessee right uh we
definitely at least plan on
homeschooling I know life can throw a
lot of things in our Direction and I
guess it depends on um you know our our
specific kids once they get to that age
but that would that would be ideal if we
could homeschool and there are know
there are things like homeschooling pods
and like online curriculum where it's
like you don't need to just be left on
your own and try to figure out like okay
when should my kid be reading I don't
know so that's it's comforting to know
that you have support now if your parent
want to do that just because I'm at a
stage where I do not trust Educators
like Educators at all I've seen way too
many videos of even in private schools
even in charter schools uh so-called
Christian Schools crazy stuff happening
um not to mention that I mean I went to
I feel like and it's it's a fine line
between wanting to protect your kids
versus overly Sheltering them but there
are just like a lot of even social
influences in schools that you know I I
remember like seeing kids be bullied or
just I guess bad things happening to my
peers that shouldn't have happened to
them and I don't think I should have
even been witnessing at the age that I
did and you know I I I know are some
people who say well yeah but they need
to be toughened up and stuff like that
it's like well the world is going to
toughen you up regardless and I you know
I just don't think that being punched as
a seven-year-old is especially helpful I
don't think anybody deserves that so uh
yeah there are just a lot of reasons why
I would prefer to homeschool and what I
love about what happened during Co there
were a lot of negatives but I think a
lot of push backs started during coid
when parents realized what was going on
in schools what their kids were learning
or being brainwashed wased with and I
think there's also just a lot of fatigue
surrounding the increasing lack of
performance from a lot of public schools
so it's been great to see that school
choice has been a huge movement that's
been growing like Charter Schools
they're becoming more popular
homeschooling is becoming more popular
there's just so many more choices for
parents in education which I think is
just so so important because I also
don't think that it's one size fits all
I know I've always been a really good
independent learner I'm happy to and I
did do independent study classes from
really time I was like 13 and I I loved
them but I know that there are a lot of
kids who just would not be able to
function like that alone with a book oh
hey you learned this and it doesn't make
them a worse learner so I think it's
also probably we may need to Pivot our
approach depending on like what our
daughter or other kids prefer and their
what their learning is like yeah yeah um
I had the same experience with my kid
like Scarlet when I was little I was
just reading all the time and I I think
I could have done everything
like myself right if you just put things
in front of me um and she's way more
social and artistic than I was and
just different so I was like we could
just set her up exactly the way that I
would be optimized learning and like
nope not exactly she's an entirely
different human yeah
apparently yeah and that's it's actually
kind of cool to see that with kids like
their own personality develop and how
they're just different from you because
I I used to there's a lot of people who
I think believe that it's all social
conditioning we're just blank slates
when we're born and then it's just our
environment that shapes us but I even
like already seeing how my daughter is
different than me I'm like where did
that come from I did not like this is
not something she picked up from me I
don't do this so it's like like she's
such a climber she wants to climb
everything she is so and I'm like I am
the least active person on the planet I
asked my mom was I doing all this when I
was younger she's like uh no I was like
like yeah so I don't I don't know what
this is from probably my husband's
side yeah
funny that's funny scarla doesn't climb
she's more like me when I was little at
least in that way so she like tricked me
I was like oh it's a little me for a
while but now she's different so it's
cute though it's
fun hey I wanted to let you guys know I
just launched my first supplement called
after party it is a hangover supplement
which is fun it's available at Fuller
health.com linked in the comments the
reviews are starting to come in so I
thought I'd just read one what black
magic is this this is the fun one I
don't know how to qualify how good this
product is I typically drink about the
same amount and even kind of beer last
night I took three pills before going to
bed I didn't even take the recommended
two in the morning I do recommend you
take two in the morning as well but this
guy didn't I woke up not just feeling
okay I felt great literally one of my
greatest feeling days of the past week
despite the fact that I don't usually
drink usually I'm sluggish and tired and
wanting a nap all day long sometimes a
bit of nausea if I do drink this morning
was literally nothing I went to the gym
did stuff around the house was super
productive I've tried everything
electrolytes water food ibuprofen
sleeping in ETC they have helped but
this actually worked amazing so yeah
there's a 30-day money back guarantee if
you don't like it free shipping in the
US it's pure with no fillers I swear
these will help make you more productive
following drinking if you do drink even
a little it's not good for you and these
make a massive difference they reduce
nausea actual alcohol damage headaches
and leave you with a nice calm chill
feeling try them let me know what you
guys think in the reviews check out
Fuller health.com code MP for 15% off
linked in the comments enjoy the rest of
this
episode what are the most valuable this
was a bunch of people asked this
question and they wanted wanted your
opinion on what the most valuable
qualities to look for in a man are oh
okay that's a good question um I would
say loyalty is really big uh definitely
one of like at least like top
five because I think from loyalty
there's so much like if you're loyal to
someone and you care about someone and
you're committed to them there are so
many things that are just easier like if
you're going through something terrible
and someone's loyal to you they're going
to want to be their for you emotionally
if you're going through something hard
financially like as as a couple and a
husband who loyal to you he's going to
you know want to be able to do what it
takes to help get you guys through this
so I think loyalty is probably one of
the biggest ones and also just having
similar values like you don't like I'm
not saying like you have to like the
same politicians necessarily but like if
you're on a date with a guy and you want
to get married and he's talking about
how he doesn't believe marriage is worth
it then don't waste your time like that
you're there are so many things in a
relationship you're going to have to
work on like as you go that if if
already from the start you're coming at
it from different perspectives it's not
it's just going to be an uphill battle
so I would say it's not worth it which I
know like nowadays people's like oh all
you need is love I actually don't
believe that I I feel like you need a
stronger Foundation than that otherwise
it's going to be really really hard um
you know after like 10 years 15 years if
you're just constantly at odds with each
other and um I would say like and it's
funny because I was on the culture war
with Tim pool and with Destiny who was
like this liberal and he actually did
make a good point is that like with
relationships people like online we
often talk a lot about like things like
money and personal like which obviously
matter but he also made the good the
good point that a lot of a relationship
is just like are you able to live
comfortably with someone and spend time
with them and I think that's that's a
really good point um especially online
like the red pill Community they can get
really erotic about like this statistic
means that this many women will be
interested or whatever it is but it's
like ultimately with a relationship
you're going to be living with this
person you're going to be like sharing a
life together you're going to need to be
able to be around and enjoy each other's
company so I think for which people who
are like not online perpetually like I
am they're going to be listening to that
and be like how is that advice like
obviously you should like the person
you're dating but I think there are a
lot of people online who need to be
reminded actually that you should just
like your spouse because like people are
more than just their body count or their
bank account or how many kids they want
to have so like don't get too neurotic
when you're dating I guess yeah I like
that do you enjoy each other's company
that's a that's a huge one though cuz I
feel like there are some people that do
enjoy each other's company but then one
of the people only wants to hang out a
little bit it's like oh I have a great
time hanging out with you but like for
like a couple of hours a day maybe and
then how's that going to translate over
over to like marriage it's not well
that's it's also interesting because I I
know a girl who's she's like an
introvert and she's with an extrovert
and I'm not saying that those
relationships can't work but I know that
for her at least it actually is hard
because sometimes like for her birthday
she just literally wanted to be able to
like go to a hotel and like have aone
time um which is like Liam and I are
both introverts so it's like we live
together but we're not always together
plus we also work together so you know
we are very happy some nights to just be
like okay we're just going to chill out
like separately at home um and I feel
like if you're not on the same page with
that like one of you is more extroverted
and they want more attention the other
one wants to be left alone like that
also could cause some friction actually
I know a couple like that too where the
guy is more introverted and he actually
says that like he's drained being with
his girlfriend he feels like he needs to
almost take vacations after his
vacations because she'll have them
booked like from like Dawn Till dust
with different social engagements and
it's tiring for him like he's exhausted
by the end of it yeah I I think figuring
out your personality or at least knowing
what you're like and then discussing
that frankly with the other person is
very
important uh I knew that if I ended up
with somebody who was introverted I'm so
extroverted like going to coffee shops
to be able to work around people even
just so I could see people I don't even
really like people but I really don't
like being alone so and if if you're
with an introvert that's going to be
that's going to be lonely you're going
to feel like you're cooped up you want
to get out there but you're almost going
to feel like the other person is you
know if they're not on the same page or
willing to let you go out and do your
own thing almost like holding you back
or trying to I guess like keep you
cooped up so it's hard on both people
for sure if you're not on the same page
yeah and if you're an introvert you're
going to feel like you're drowning all
the time yeah probably yeah I think
neuroticism too is a huge one that plays
a role like I think if one person is an
anxious person and is stressed out they
can be with someone who's stable but I
think having two anxious people together
is also like not a great idea for
long-term success yeah yeah I think
other like other personality traits
might work but neuroticism and
extraversion conscientiousness though as
well yeah definitely I mean I know like
and even like we're my husband and I
we're pretty well matched on most things
but even like with with uh
conscientiousness so I'm messier than he
is and I feel like unless we were
willing to be like okay I'm going to
keep things tidier than I would
personally like and he's going to have
to deal with things not being as tidy as
he would like that's also like a point
of where that could very easily lead to
contention and it's funny so I like you
have you ever been on like R
relationships or R SL like am I the
[__] like there are these posts where
people will blow up at each other over
like a trivial thing and everyone in the
comments is like it's not actually about
this thing you guys have deeper issues
and this just happened to be the the
straw that broke the camel's back and I
feel like if you're not matched on
things like introversion versus
extraversion conscientiousness or even
neuroticism like those kind of
underlying tensions kind of set the
stage for maybe one day something's
going to happen and you're both going to
act very uncharitably toward each other
but it's not actually about like that
one incident it's about the resentment
or the frustration that's been building
up kind of in the background Underneath
It All yeah that's perfect I also think
one mistake people can make when they're
dating is
um being okay this is a mistake that
I've made so that's why I'm bringing it
up but is being interested in someone
who's extroverted and isn't
conscientious like so they're very
disorganized but they're so much fun and
being like oh this could work like the
extroversion is really showing up here
and then that just doesn't work out long
term because all you're seeing is
somebody who's extroverted and exciting
and maybe ambitious but the background
the depth isn't there that's something
like
I think women who are attracted to
extroverts need to be aware
of yeah and I think there's also I don't
know if men go for as much but I could
see there are definitely a lot of like
Online female figures who are maybe like
Instagram influencers who might be a
similar story but if a guy actually want
something deeper that may not be the
right person to to search for that with
yeah definitely okay what about values
men should look for in
women um I would say like again loyalty
super important um and for women and
it's funny because like right now
there's like there's a lot of women are
getting in the red pill Community
especially which is I it's not the same
as the conservative movement at all but
you know because both communities are
critical of feminism and like things
like hookup culture I feel like we kind
of exist like adjacent to each other um
so women are getting a really bad rap in
the red pill Community as just like
terrible nowadays and I don't think
that's true there are a lot of good
women out there like I'm friends with
many many great women um values that I
think it's important or attributes that
I think is important for a woman to have
absolutely like loyalty and commitment
to family um and I feel like there's a
lot of selfishness that are that is
being pushed onto women not that women
are innately more selfish than men it's
just that I feel like Society almost
tries to tell a lot of young women that
it's a good thing for them to be more
self-interested as a form of empowerment
um which is not something men to the
same degree are being told so it's
something that has I think blossomed
more in women and I think I would be
very weary of that if if you're a man
just
because like I mean you might think it's
just kind of annoying or Quirk but if
you're trying to build a life with
someone and they're always looking out
mostly for themselves instead of like
you guys as a couple or even your kids I
think it's going to you're going to find
that you don't have as much of of a
partner as you probably are going to
need throughout your life yeah that's
true tricky too cuz even in the kind of
what would the category of people be
like self-help self- betterment
Community I don't know what that
Community is uh but it can be
conservative as well you're told
optimize yourself I think men are
actually told this more is like build up
yourself because you're number one and
then everything else will kind of fall
into place and I do think it kind of
changes when you get into a relationship
where you can't just be number one
at least not all the time or it doesn't
work out like you have to be aiming
towards the same thing and I feel like
men are kind of told like build yourself
up a lot which is good you should build
yourself up but it's like women are told
do what makes you happy a lot I hear
that a lot or like follow your heart and
stuff like that um and I don't think
that's really good advice like I mean
it's not always the worst advice but I
don't think those are words to live by
because I feel like there are a lot of
things that might be fleetingly a good
idea or that might feel good at the time
or make you happy at the time but that
are ultimately bad decisions in the long
term and like just on social media I see
the way a lot of young women are
behaving and it's like I can understand
from like a lizard B brain perspective
why that's making you happy in the
moment but I don't think this is
actually what's good for you in the long
term yeah that no that's true I went to
so I got quite sick in University and I
dropped out of University and moved back
home and decided to become a makeup
artist when I was
20 and my dad almost had a heart
attack he was like you're not going to
be intellectually stimulated what are
you doing with your life and I was like
and then mom was like do what your heart
wants and and I went to makeup school
for about 6 months and just died of
boredom there and I have nothing against
I mean I learned some makeup tricks and
I use makeup all the time so it's not
like it was a waste of time but uh
there's definitely something to be said
especially when you're young not NE
necessarily just doing what you think
makes you happy like ideally you do what
makes you happy in the long run but it's
really hard to figure out what actually
makes you happy right and it's probably
not those fleeting things that you
appreciate when you're probably under
like 23 at least for me I think my brain
fully grew in when I was 23 or 24 like
it took a
while yeah and I feel like when we're
younger as well we we think of like
happiness just in terms of just like
pleasure what's pleasurable for me in
the moment whereas I feel when we get
older we start to look for things that
are actually more meaningful and that
give us fulfillment which is a different
kind of happiness but sometimes it's the
type of fulfillment that actually
requires some shortterm unpleasantness
whether that's working really hard to
set up a business so that you can have
something that you know you do love
doing that's also financially viable or
you know even with a family sometimes
that could be really hard work getting
set up and you know worrying about
things like buying a house and stuff
like that but it's for the longer term
goal and and that's just something when
you're younger you probably you might
think is is not worthwhile but it's like
your brain is very different when you're
younger you're not geared toward
long-term consequences so if if young
people are watching this I guess my
advice would be like be aware that the
choices you make now may not be the ones
you would make in the future which I
know if you're young is really hard to
hear I would not have appreciate being
told that but it's true yeah yeah it is
true you'd also think you know what does
she know and I I know myself well enough
yes but maybe some of that could be
mitigated by doing more long-term
planning like what are the long-term
goals you want and then work towards
those don't work towards these shortterm
goals as much because I think that's
probably where the like hedonistic stuff
comes in maybe like I I don't think
you're going to be you know what how how
do I want to look as a 50-year-old I
don't think only fans necessarily comes
into play there right yeah so um okay
you talked about the red pill Community
what are your I I switched directions on
the red pill community so I don't think
I knew very much about it I just heard
of it and I've been thinking you know I
think they've got some points and I
think because of this war on masculinity
the red pill Community is warranted
because they're supportive of men I
didn't actually realize how much hatred
of women was involved in the red Bill
Community until I started doing a little
bit more digging but uh what what are
your thoughts on people like f uh fit
and fresh and that kind of group of
people you think it's useful or damaging
so I'm not I've heard about fit and
fresh I've never watched any of their
podcasts I think I've seen like clips of
them but I mean just like my impression
of the red pill Community as a whole I
think there are some very valid
criticisms out there from the red pill
community of things like feminism of
things like the court system and the way
that it is weighted against men but the
more that I look into the red pill
Community it's kind of ironic because
you know the the whole red pill analogy
it comes from the Matrix and taking the
red pill is supposed to symbolize seeing
the world as it really is but there's a
lot of narratives that are being pushed
in the red pill community that are just
not representative of the world as it
really is it's I feel like in some cases
they've almost gone too far the opposite
way believing that you know um I I I saw
someone online posting that like 80% of
divorces are initiated by women and it's
even worse for college educated women
it's 90% of uh divorces like therefore
like don't marry someone who like don't
marry a woman who's gone to college
she's like 90% chance she's going to
leave you and it's like actually college
educated women are much less likely to
get divorced than women who've only gone
to high school there's a difference
between saying that 90% of college
educated women who are married get
divorced versus of divorces that happen
with college educated women 90% of them
are initiated like that's a different
thing and there's also research going
into why divorces are initiated in the
first place and one of the top reasons
is infidelity I I think it's pretty hard
to argue that the person who cheated is
not the one who is responsible for
ending the marriage rather the one who
simply submitted the paperwork for it
like if we're actually talking about who
tore up the relationship here so there's
like a lot of stuff like that that I
feel like there's very cursory research
being done H and people are kind of
choosing statistics to fit their
narrative which we see all the time in
this St just not specific to the red
pill Community but um like yeah I you
know I appreciate the the attempt to
push back against a lot of the toxic
behaviors that we see but there's also
you know I've seen also I think from
fresh and fit the you we can condemn uh
female promis cuity but they almost
defend male promis cuity which is like
okay well that's that's very strange and
like if you you I often hear feminists
being called Hypocrites I don't know how
you can have that position without it
also being very very
hypocritical I feel like that's new now
I'm not that familiar with with red pill
stuff but from what I'd seen in like
2012 is I don't remember I it was like
that in 2012 either yeah like that seems
to be something that's like since 2020
where it was oh men are supposed to be
promiscuous and have multiple women but
women are always attached to one alpha
male that seems to have popped up in the
last like 3 years I don't even know how
that started cuz Cassy J like she did a
movie called The Red Pill and it was
basically just about um men's rights
issue ises which I think are very
important and kind of criticizing a lot
of the more radical parts of modern day
feminism which again like I think if
that's all it was I I'm on board with
that and I think there are some people
in the red pill Community who still
speak on that and that's great but
there's also like very weird narratives
that they've started inserting
surrounding relationships which is where
I'm like I don't know where you're
getting this where they're basically
telling men not to be in relationships
with women at all and it's like you
sound like a radfem like you sound
exactly like a radfem right now
um and it's funny because I've seen so
many feminists say that marriage and
children are a patriarchal invention and
I've also seen red pillars say that
marriage and children are a matriarchal
invention it's only women who are trying
to trap you and it's like what men want
to get married and have kids too like
that can make a man happy as well it's
not like I it's just very strange I
think a lot of the people in those
communities just need to go outside and
touch grass and speak to someone of the
opposite sex who is not online frankly
well I'm glad you've noticed that too I
think the reason why I was kind of on
board with red pill things was because
it was different just like the like
liberals were different pre 20102 I
swear the red pill Community was
different too and it was more based
around men's rights and less based
around women hatred uh not a huge fan of
it at the moment yeah and I feel like
for people who are watching this who
aren't familiar with the red pill
Community the term woman hatred gets
like misused a lot but there are act
like this is we're being serious here
like I've seen like female nature is
just to lie and deceive and it's like
the male nature is Honorable and like
all of these is like what like this is a
car what are you guys talking about it's
actually it's hilarious it's basically
as ridiculous as some of the extreme
feminist stuff you would read but
instead of ragging on men they're
ragging on women yeah that was a good
clarification this isn't this isn't like
liberal women hatred this is like actual
yeah I think I got aggravated by it
because I got divorced
and I got the people that were after me
online were from the red pill Community
who have like no idea about and I
haven't made anything public about like
why I got divorced or anything I'm not
going to but I think growing up I had a
view because my dad did have
conservative values even though I said
that he it was kind of a liberal
household he had very conservative
values on marriage and obviously a
stable family is better for children if
that's something that you can manage but
I think and that was solidly my view and
then I ended up in a situation where I
needed to get divorced and it was such a
like mind [__] for lack of a better word
because I was like this isn't something
that would happen to me I'm really like
I think I'm good at negotiating am I bad
at negotiating like why can't I make
this work what's wrong with me and why
can't I make this work and then it gave
me a lot more sympathy
for for I think
divorces and I don't know like the
statistics around divorces are pretty
rough there are a lot of people getting
divorced and my view used to be well
that's because people aren't taking
marriage seriously and then you see
celebrities like it was Emma radowski
probably saying that wrong who went
viral being like Oh I think it's like
she I think it's Chic to be divorced by
the time you're 30 which is I think what
the R pill Community looks at and it's
like that's what a woman is but and so
that was what my view of people who got
divorced were were people who weren't
taking marriage seriously but then it
happened to me and I feel like well that
left me with more compassion I probably
went too far in the other direction
where I was like oh you got divorced
what happened to you like something must
have happened whereas before the divorce
I was more on the side of well why
didn't you negotiate your way out of it
something something
fault so that's probably where the like
more irritation at the red pill
Community came from like compassion
there is a huge lack of compassion and I
like I've seen things about like single
mothers and yeah like they are selfish
it's like well you don't know like if
someone like like is collecting welfare
and just trying to like have as many
kids as possible with different baby
daddy like yeah obviously that's
repulsive Behavior but it's like I know
single moms who are single moms because
the their husband their father like
they've literally abandoned them like
how like and people like oh well that's
a fringe case like how do you know how
much of a fringe or not Fringe case it
is that's the thing like you you don't
care either you'd rather just condemn
People based on your gender stereotypes
and that's frustrating to me and I also
don't think it's constructive to help
people and also like you know talking
about the idea that red pillow is
supposed to mean reality it's just
you've you're so far into your rabbit
hole of just like wanting to see the
world as you think it is I.E women are
evil that like do you really think that
for like the 75% of uh children who are
born to single mothers in the black
community that there are just like their
fathers are begging to take care of them
more and the moms are like no I'm going
to like withhold custody because I hate
you like cuz obviously that's not what's
happening uh so yeah there is just
frustrations that I I have there um
because it's just like again it's it's
not representative of reality which is
supposed to be what the red pill
Community is about
yeah that was very well said that was
very well said that was much that was
much more Lucid than what I was going to
say that was great had time to like fume
over this like on Twitter
so I was like I'm not going to get
involved I'm not going to get involved
but it's too
annoying it's too bothersome okay last
question um how do you
manage criticism because you are like a
a popular conservative voice and so how
do you manage the stress of online
criticism that's actually a really good
question and I feel like that's
something I've gotten better at as time
has gone on like I don't know if you do
you remember the first mean comment you
ever
got probably not like casually mean but
I definitely remember when there were a
number of them about one topic and it
was extremely stressful yeah right
because people don't talk to each other
like that in the real world and if
you're in a regular job you're almost
never going to be in a situation where
you just have like random people say
terrible things to you so I remember the
first time I got like a lot of criticism
on like a video too and I well I was
kind of like I couldn't believe that
someone would say that to me it was like
it stressed me out it was it was you
know I I felt the need to address
everything and the the longer I've kind
of been online I've come to realize that
actually you don't need to address every
critic ISM and that doesn't mean that
you ignore all criticism but it's just
being able to discern like what is a
troll what is just malicious versus
actually legitimate like oh maybe I'll
like this is something I I should think
about and introspection um and it's like
I've kind of I've told myself with like
response videos I very much maintain
anyone can make a response video to me I
like that's your right as a video
creator I make response videos but I no
longer and may maybe I shouldn't say
this in case there's like an egregious
one I want to respond to but I no longer
like will resp respond to an
individual video about me because I feel
like there's just the the risk that it
becomes too much about saving my own ego
versus actually addressing criticism so
I guess my Approach now is that you know
don't address specific people but if
there's a a criticism that keeps coming
up across different people different
videos maybe then it's something to to
consider um but simultaneously I also
kind of believe that if you wouldn't
take advice from someone you probably
shouldn't worry too much about their
criticism um because there are like you
know there are a lot of specifically
leftists out there who hate everything I
do um and at certain points like you
can't please these people so it's like
you know I'm I'm at a pretty good place
where I don't let it bother me but at
the same time I never want to be at a
place where I just I think no criticism
is valid because that's not true of
anybody like everyone's got something to
be criticized about yeah I think you
just get used to it and you're like oh
it shouldn't evoke this kind of
emotional response as as it did at the
beginning
right I was just going to say I've I've
seen people um kind of like other online
creators who get really popular really
fast and they're really good at what
they do but they actually end up
essentially rage quitting because of the
criticism because it gets to you and I
um I know like if you're not in that
position it might see like what you were
like this huge YouTuber or Twitter
personality and you just like you quit
because people were me you online and
it's like it it almost sounds like why
would you give it up and is I like I I
don't think I would do it myself but I
understand it cuz if you know if you're
the type of person um who is maybe very
like I don't want to say more sensitive
because it almost sounds like you're
just dismissing their feelings but um I
I understand how that is is really hard
on people and for some people it just
might not be worth it like the the money
you might be able to make or the
popularity you might be able to have
it's just not worth it to your mental
health at a point it's also
understandable because you grow up
taking say in high school like when you
get negative feedback sometimes it's
because your your behavior is wrong so
you get all this negative feedback and
it kind of helps hone you into the
person you are like you people need the
negative feedback and they need to
experience negativity towards that
especially if they're acting out so as a
kid like you can't just be this wild kid
or your friends aren't going to like you
and then them not liking you changes
your behavior in a positive way but
that's yeah but then that's not exactly
how works if you have a massive audience
and you have a whole bunch of like
losers that are coming after you for
lack of a better descriptor what are you
going to do Cas so that wasn't the last
question do you have any tentative plan
for um your kiddo like and social
media what do you oh like am I going to
let her on social media or yeah or are
there have you put into in any thought
about how you're going to tell her how
to respond to social
media that's a good question I mean we
have haven't really put in thought about
how we're going to help her respond to
social media um like in terms of we
definitely don't want her to have her
own social media accounts young um you
know my husband and I we've discussed
like having kind of like old school a
family computer a family tablet just so
we can all like there's a lot of things
that could happen online to a kid that
may maybe were still possible when I was
younger but I think are just so much
more likely now and it's kind of hard
cuz as a parent with something like a
cell phone I understand wanting to be
able to reach your kid especially if
they're at a friend's house or something
that communication is valuable but I
think like you know even if they're a
teen like we have Liam's cousins they
have cell phones but they're not
smartphones and I think that's a pretty
good that's a pretty good balance of
wanting to make sure that they're
reachable for safety reasons but also
that you know there's a lot of apps
Snapchat uh I think Instagram as well
that I just don't see how they could be
beneficial to a teen and I say that as
someone who spends a lot of time on
social media media but that's why I know
that they're not very healthy things I
don't think they're a good place for
anybody really let alone um especially a
young person Yeah It's Tricky so that
that's kind of how I've been leaning but
then I also am
concerned uh that Scarlet will go to
school and then everybody it's it
doesn't matter if everybody at school is
doing something your kid shouldn't do
that doesn't mean that you should just
do it but I also don't want her to be
the kid that doesn't do do something
everybody else does and so I've spent
quite a bit of time thinking are there
boundaries I could put in so that it was
safe so that she's not alienated if her
entire like I don't know what's going to
happen in in five years what what kids
are going to be like or what school's
going to be like like are there
boundaries you can put in place and I
guess we'll see like how things develop
but it's hard it's tricky it's really
hard especially like uh I have a family
member who is I think nine and her her
parents aren't letting her have Tik Tok
but guess what she has friends who are
on Tik Tok and then they watch Tik Tok
together so it's like okay well
basically your child now has Tik Tok um
and that kind of goes back to I was
saying like another thing to consider
with school is also your peer Choice um
you don't want to be overprotective as a
parent but also like you don't want to
Via proxy just allow someone else to
essentially decide how your parenting
goes or decide what your kid is exposed
to so it's really hard and it's just
with social media it's a lot harder than
I think previous generations have had it
like our parents didn't have to navigate
this to the extent that we are yeah I
got in enough trouble over MSN yeah I
remember yeah it was just MSN and that
led to a host of problems and that is
nothing like what kids are dealing with
now exactly I remember when I was in
like fifth and sixth grade there was
like a lot of drama that was happening
over MSN so yeah for sure yeah do you
remember honesty box on Facebook no okay
really early on in like super early
Facebook days there was something called
honesty box and you could go on
somebody's profile and leave them a
comment nobody could see except you and
them but it was completely Anonymous oh
I could see how that would be very
damaging to people they got rid of that
really quickly I think it was in there
for 2 years and it was just a mess so I
yeah I could imagine yikes yeah well
Lauren thank you very much for coming on
that was fun yeah thank you so much for
having me it's always a always a fun
[Music]
chat